with the rising number of dengue fever
patients it's becoming increasingly
difficult for both government and
private hospital to code in many
hospital there's hardly any space left
among the 200 patients that we are
getting admitted in this hospital at
least 150 to 170 patients are suffering
from diagnosis of dengue fever and among
them a significant number of the
patients are presenting with the
features of dengue shock syndrome in
many cases patients are having to move
from one hospital to another often not
finding a vacant beds and returning home
without treatment I had a fever for
around three days then I decided to go
see a doctor at the hospital he
suggested that I take a dengue test the
next day I got my results which showed
it to be positive so I got admitted
immediately the worst-hit are 15 to 25
year olds of both sexes my roommate my
roommate came down with a high fever he
suffered for several days until he was
diagnose with dengue fever we didn't
realize at first he had dengue and after
a few days I came down with a high fever
and after the diagnosis it turns out I'd
caught dengue but they did they are more
bingley hurdles the government recently
launched an awareness campaign and
fumigation operation to control the
spread of mosquito-borne diseases if we
think about the magnitude of the dengue
outbreak
it's an outbreak and it's a large
outbreak not a small outbreak even in
comparison to previous years we are
having I think the gap is huge so it's
large number of patients are suffering
an estimated 400 million people
worldwide suffer the painful
debilitating disease every year doctors
usually advise pain relievers rest and
to drink plenty of liquids
health experts suspect that Eddie's
species of mosquitoes which carries the
virus may have already spread outside
the capital Dhaka Bangladesh is
struggling with one of the worst
outbreak of dengue fever in the past 20
years the situation is getting back to
worse with number of dead
steadily increasing along
with patients needing treatment doctors
fear they will get even more busier
during the Eid holidays in few days
sandwich Audrey al-jazeera Dhaka
Bangladesh